well joey botto's early ejection
yesterday actually turned into a
feel-good story right and ohio who now
lives in california tweeted a photo of
her six-year-old daughter abigail's face
after explaining that her favorite
player vado was no longer playing in the
game and the reds immediately went into
action and this is from joey i am sorry
i didn't play the entire game he signed
the baseball they left tickets for the
family today a feel-good story in the
end her fandom cemented forever 28 year
old right-hander to nelson lumet
toes the slap today making his second
career start versus the cincinnati reds
first one since 2017 when nelson was a
rookie
and run support is a key but
see what he does pitch count wise he
hasn't eclipsed 80 yet but he's built up
hopefully he can do that today
in front of india a ball in two strikes
and he got it
strikeout number one for nelson lumet 98
mile per hour pace
here's tyler naquin started the first
two games of the series in center field
he's in right today with castiano's
getting the day off got him one two
three time of the first inning for
nelson lament they take on the getting
good luis castillo numbers from western
and southern well his stuff has always
been there all year had a horrible month
of april of just as bad month in may
people were beginning to really worry
about castillo but as long as his health
was there
and his fastball tipping around 97-98
he's going to be all right he began to
find the groove last time out and the
time before that oh for a pitcher to get
it
swinging a miss at 100 blows the
fastball by grisham what a way
here's will myers speaking of hitting
the ball hard two home runs
a couple of doubles in this series first
pitch swinging hot shot to the shortstop
but he won hops it farmer farmer's gonna
flip it over to india for the out so the
padres hitting the ball hard the last
couple of bats but nothing to show for
motto on first and bornheart strikes out
number three for denelson lament well it
was a slider that sets up this fastball
earlier in the county threw the slider
down and in up and away is the fastball
missing that barrel
suarez with another ugly swing of the
miss in back-to-back strikeouts for
lumet two down in the second inning so
interesting jesse because with joey
votto on first he does not have speed
but lumet elects to go to the slide step
with a slider awkward swing by suarez
that puts runners on first and second
now with two away and will myers with a
chance to do some damage wall in two
strikes
and will shoots that one the other way
deep to right naquin to the corner and
it is a fair ball up against the wall
machado is scored here comes hosmer
will's on his way to third a two run
triple to now the ball gets away he's
gonna come all the way home
padres take a three to nothing lead will
myers feeling very comfortable against
luis castillo
it's a pretty good pitch down and away
you see the change up off the end of the
bat and will myers does what he does
best going the other way inside the foul
pole
and eric cosmer really had a very good
read on this pitch and he's hustling
around and joey votto with the errant
throw to third base scoring will myers
on the little league home run
vanessa now gives you a chance to get
out of the inning runners at first and
third now you've got a ground ball
situation with grisham
who runs well by the way
0-2
grounded past castillo farmer hits the
bag one on the first in time double play
runner on second two outs here in the
top of the fifth inning
trying to get through five for just the
second time this year as a starting
pitcher talking about the pitch count
for nelson he hasn't gone above 78 this
season
so could be working in his final inning
here in the fifth
pitching with a three-nothing lead
farmer on second two down two and two to
winker and a slow roller jake
cronenworth is there and then nelson
lamette through five shutout innings
awesome kim
has had a very strong
three-week run he's been excellent in
the series
[Applause]
swinging a miss 98 with life from
castillo
he's got seven strikeouts
well that matches the number of
strikeouts that he had his last timeout
and this one a four seamer that goes
right above the bat
sharp ground ball backhand suarez
shortstop pole throw a bouncer envato
definitely digs it out of the dirt
nicely done pinching single
by castianos loads the bases for the
reds here in the seventh inning still
one down in the top of the order
jonathan india coming up india today
over two with a walk
and the big home run in the ninth inning
on thursday night
double play depth
wouldn't that be great for craig stamin
to try to induce a double play
indy a hard hit grounder right to kim
that's one
that is the inning
craig stamen all fired up
as the padres roll the inning ending
double play here in the top of the
seventh here's tyler stevenson came in
as a pinch hitter in the sixth round it
out to the first baseman hosmer now he
bats
with winker on at first base and nobody
out vado on deck and then aquino
well hit to left field that's down to
base hit
winker through second pro far bare hands
winker shut down at third and the reds
first extra base hit of the game a
standing double smashed by stevenson
bottom
smothered cronenworth to first winker
scores
stevenson over to third rbi for joey
votto reds on the board it's three to
one
well hit hard by votto i mean he is all
over that one and just
a one hopper to the second baseman makes
a nice play
so now the tying run
in scoring position
suarez 0 for three
2-2
suarez
pirouette machado throw to first in time
stevenson crosses
aquino over to third base another rbi
ground out the reds within a run this is
why pitching coach and
run preventive specialists in front
offices love swinging
misses
it's a nice play my machado i mean
completely outstretched right there
so now the tying run just 90 feet away
after the stolen base aquino moving up
to third on that ground out here is
akiyama 1-0 pitch and akiyama crushes
one deep right center field going back
on it myers and on the warning track
just in front of the wall he makes the
catch will come to bat with a man on and
two outs here in the top of the ninth
inning
winker in the air shallow right field
kim going back he will make the catch
over the shoulder
how fitting is that
awesome kim tracks it down and the
padres complete the four-game sweep of
the cincinnati reds
their first four-game sweep of any team
since 2011.